You're back exclusively with
New York Congressman Hakeem Jeffries,
who is running
unopposed to become the leader
of the Democrats in the House.
Congressman, thanks so much
for staying with us.
What is your relationship
like with your Republican counterpart,
Kevin McCarthy,
who wants to be the speaker?
When was the last time
you spoke with him?
I haven't had a conversation
with Leader McCarthy Carthy recently.
I do have,
I think, a much warmer relationship
with Steve Scalise.
Look forward to working
whenever and wherever possible.
However, Jake,
with the entire House
Republican Conference
and the leadership team
to find common ground
to get things done
for everyday Americans to make progress.
But of course, we will fiercely
and vigorously
oppose any attempts
at Republican overreach
and any Republican extremism.
And I'm hopeful
that the Republican leadership
will take lessons away
from the rejection of extremism
by the American people
all across the land
and not double and triple down on it
in the next Congress.
Do you think he's fit
to be the next leader,
Kevin McCarthy,
the next leader of the Republicans?
You've had some harsh words for him
saying it's impossible
to take him seriously.
And when people ask you about
Kevin McCarthy,
you say, Kevin,
who do you think he's fit
to be speaker of the House?
Well, that's
a decision ultimately
that the House Republican Conference
is going to have to make.
He does seem to be struggling
to get the two way team.
Let's see what happens on January 3rd.
There is going to be
because of the narrow majority that House
Republicans are going to have,
the far
right wing,
the MAGA caucus is going to be empowered
and emboldened.
It's going to make it tougher
for McCarthy to govern as speaker
if he does, in fact, become speaker.
If Kevin McCarthy needs votes to pass
essential legislation
such as keeping the government open
or raising the debt limit.
Will Democrats be willing to help him
if the Freedom Caucus folks the Marjorie
Taylor Greens of the world
refuse to participate
Well, it seems to me
that that's a case by case basis.
But Democrats have always been willing
to lean in on making sure
that we fully fund the government.
And Democrats
have always been willing to lean in
and making sure
that we meet
our nation's
obligations and do not default
on our debt.
For the first time in American history,
I think it's also important
to point out, Jake,
that we have consistently
fought against extremism
on the Republican side,
including when it manifested itself often
during the former president's tenure,
while at the same time
being able to find common ground
to make progress for the American people.
We did it with criminal justice reform.
I was delighted to be involved
personally
in trying to negotiate a historic
criminal justice reform
with the Trump administration
and working with my colleague,
former Republican Congressman
Doug Collins from Georgia.
Certainly, Speaker Pelosi led the effort
to make sure
that we could arrive at an agreement
around the U.S.
Mexico-Canada
trade agreement, reform, the new NAFTA
in a way
that benefited working families
organized labor
and people from the heartland
and throughout the country.
And we consistently
have found common ground,
even with some of the most
recent legislative victories
during this current Congress.
I hope that that's a record
that we can build upon moving forward.
House Republicans announced this week
their oversight plans,
which include
taking a look at the withdrawal
from Afghanistan,
the origins of COVID,
the FBI search at Mar a Lago.
I can see that there could be
theoretically legitimate
oversight questions
on each of those topics
that could be asked
Will House
Democrats participate
in these investigations in good faith?
Or do you see it as your role
to defend the Biden administration?
Well, we will absolutely
defend the Biden administration
and his track record of success
if it comes under assault
by people attempting to politicize
our governmental responsibilities,
without question.
And I expect that we will strongly
and vigorously
be involved
in pushing back against any effort
at overreach by the extreme MAGA
Republican wing of the House
Republican Conference.
At the same time, we're going to continue
to try
to find common ground legislatively
whenever possible
I think that the time for politics ends
in the immediate aftermath of a campaign,
and it has to be some space to govern.
That's what
the American people
Democrats, Republicans,
independents, people in the North,
the South, the East, the West,
the Midwest want to see happen.
Democrats are willing
to lean into that regard.
I'm hopeful
that my Republican colleagues
will join us.
Lastly, sir, Elon Musk reinstated
Donald Trump to Twitter yesterday
just to remind folks at home
Trump wasn't banned for mean tweets.
He was banned
because he used the platform
to incite a violent insurrection
on the Capitol.
What's your reaction to Trump
being reinstated on Twitter?
You know, I have no
reaction at this point
in time
to anything that Elon Musk
or Donald Trump
does, particularly
as it relates to social media.
I am going to continue
to try to lean into the principles
of equal protection
under the law,
liberty and justice for all government
of the people by the people
and for the people,
and build upon the amazing progress
that House
Democrats
have brought to bear in partnership
with Senate
Democrats and President Biden
and continue to push for
American exceptionalism
throughout the country.
All right,
Congressman Hakeem Jeffries,
Democrat of New York,
and likely the next
leader of House Democrats.
It would be a historic moment.
Congressman, congratulations
ahead of time.
Thanks for joining us today.
Thank you, Jake.